let's go next to our caller from the
two-to-four area code who's calling
today from 2:00 to 4:00 hey lose me yes
it is okay David I was talking to my
friends about foreign policy especially
in regards to Iran
yeah and how the trumpet creation has
been saber rattling pretty much their
entire time yes and Bolton being gone a
bit of a reassurance but with this
fiasco with the oil fields in Saudi
Arabia and they're placing US troops to
guard those oil fields almost like bait
yeah it seems like we're continuing to
build up now I heard that if since war
with Iran is such a non popular idea the
Trump administration is actually waiting
until after re-election do you think
that's possible do you think that's
possible that's totally possible it's
also possible that Donald Trump I mean
Trump doesn't always listen to advice he
may say Oh a war will help me win
reelection in 2020 so we shouldn't
underestimate the possibility that he
would escalate sooner as a result of
that but yeah I mean I you know
initially when people saw Bolton leaving
who were saying oh now there's no chance
of a war with Iran no no no there it
could be under different circumstances
it could be motivated in different ways
but I don't think that threat of war
with Iran is gone now that John Bolton
is gone I completely agree with you yeah
thank you okay thanks appreciate it it
sounded like he was on speaker but it
was good enough I figured I wouldn't
interrupt with that